bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous
parler des livres pour apprendre à
compter c'est une figure obligée de la
littérature jeunesse et vous allez voir
qu'elle a fait sa révolution
le premier livre dont je voulais vous
parler c'est celui ci 1-2-3 varicelle de
claudia bielinsky paru aux éditions
casterman
l'histoire est simple une épidémie de
varicelle se propage dans une classe de
maternelle
le principe est simple il va falloir
compter les boutons cachés sous les
flaps des boutons en tissu et en relief
c'est très amusant c'est ludique et ça
permettra aux jeunes enfants de
dédramatiser la maladie
en voici un autre livre pour apprendre à
compter jusqu'à 10 les toutous ça compte
d'eva kozyra pas la coédition forme à
une petite annonce a été déposée dans la
ville de saintes rue fais pour proposer
d'adopter un ou deux chiens abandonnés
et le jeune lecteur va suivre tous les
chiens qui se porte volontaire pour être
adopté et au delà d'apprendre à compter
jusqu'à 10 c'est bien le les enfants
vont pouvoir apprendre à lire un plan
j'ai adoré ce livre en raison de
l'histoire déjà qui parle d'adoption
d'offrir l'asile à des chiens un petit
peu cabossée mais aussi en raison de sa
mise en page
vous le voyez tout est fait à partir de
morceaux de tissus cousus sur piqué à la
main et ça a pris cinq mois à l'auteur
pour réaliser l ce magnifique pas de
choix en plus au niveau de la langue
eh bien il ya énormément de petits jeux
de mots puisque le grand-père qui
propose d'adopter les chiens habite rue
mistigri et les autres rues de la ville
de saintes rue fès et bien s'appelle rue
audrey tautou rue milou jovovich que
l'histoire est écrite en rimes je vous
le conseille c'est un vrai coup de coeur
ne passez pas à côté ça apprendra bien
plus qu'à compter jusqu'à 10 et enfin
c'est une
n'est pas d'avoir des animaux de
compagnie il nous faut ce livre ça
s'appelle 365 pas moins c'est 2 jean-luc
fromental et joëlle jolivet essai paru
aux éditions hélium histoire et loufoque
imaginez vous qu'un matin vous receviez
un colis avec un pingouin 100 mo sans
explication est que cela se poursuit
comme ça pendant des jours et des jours
jusqu'à avoir de nombreux pensionnaires
chez vous alors il va falloir les
comptes et les nourrir et peut-être les
classer alors ce livre permet
d'approcher des opérations simples comme
l'addition la soustraction la
multiplication mais aussi et bien le
classement
c'est un très joli livre très amusant
très drôle qui aborde aussi le problème
du réchauffement climatique
je vous le conseille et vous le voyez et
bien grâce aux animaux et aux calculs on
apprend à compter mais aussi à être plus
généreux